during their one day informal meeting in
brussels european union leaders
cautiously welcomed the ukrainian
ceasefire agreement reached in minsk
the president of the european council
donald dusk stressed that what is now on
paper needs to translate into reality on
the ground
we are very cautious because
after
bad experiences
with
so-called mean squan
it's it's obvious that we have to be
very cautious and of course our
trust
in goodwill of
president putin is limited
the fight against terrorism was also on
the agenda following the attacks in
paris in january
we'll cooperate together to face
this threat
not with emotion or overreaction
but with calm and determination
we have agreed of on new priorities in
the fight
against
terrorism
what is needed
most
if agreement on the exchange of
passenger records within
records within the european union we
need this soon eu leaders agreed more
could be done under the existing rules
to step up checks on travelers entering
or leaving the passport-free schengen
zone
there was also discussion on how to
improve economic policy in the eurozone
the main focus was on reinforcing
structural reforms and deepening the
economic and monetary union
although the council did not debate
greece the head of the eurogroup briefed
the leaders on the ongoing discussions
ahead of next monday's key eurogroup
meeting regarding the country's debt